- [Instructor] In this
video, we're going to review
what we've already learned
about monopsony employers,
that we've covered in a previous video,
but then we're going to add a twist
of adding a minimum wage
and see what happens.
And it's actually interesting.
It's actually somewhat counterintuitive.
So just as a bit of a review,
when we're talking about
a monopsony generally,
we're talking about one buyer and many,
many sellers.
So when we're talking
about a monopsony employer,
that one buyer is the one
employer that might be,
say, in a small town, and
they're the big industry there.
And they're the only person
that a lot of folks could work for.
And then the many sellers,
well, those are all of the workers,
the people who are selling their labor.
And we've already talked
about the rational quantity
of labor that that monopsony
employer would hire.
So you have your wage,
and on that axis, that's in dollars.
You have your quantity of labor
on the horizontal axis.
We could think about our downward-sloping
marginal revenue product of labor.
Every incremental unit of labor,
you might get a little bit
lower and lower marginal revenue
from that input.
So this is our marginal
revenue product, MRP.
We could call it marginal
revenue product of labor
'cause you could also have
marginal revenue product
of capital or of land,
other factors of production.
But we're talking about employment here.
And then we could think about
the marginal factor cost.
Now, this is a significant difference
between a monopsony employer
and an employer in a perfectly
competitive labor market.
If we were dealing with a perfectly
competitive labor market,
then the employer would just
have to pay the market wage.
And so the marginal factor cost,
the amount that they would have to pay
for an incremental unit of
labor, will just be a constant,
whatever the market wage of labor is.
So that would be the marginal factor cost.
And it would be rational,
if this was not a monopsony employer,
to just keep hiring more and more,
as long as the marginal revenue product
is higher than the marginal,
this flat marginal factor cost curve,
which is set by the market wage rate.
So it would produce or it
would hire, I should say,
this quantity of labor.
But for a monopsony employer,
you could view them as, in
a lot of ways, they are the,
the labor market is,
they are the only buyer
in the labor market.
And so we could think about
a supply curve of labor
just for their market or
just for their industry
or just for them really.
And so it could look something like this.
So this is the supply of labor,
supply,
supply of labor.
And we've talked about that this is not
the marginal factor cost curve
for the monopsony employer.
Because even though that
first person might be willing
to work for this wage and then
the very next unit of labor
might be willing to work
for a slightly higher wage,
if you have to give that
slightly higher wage
to the second person, we
assume that whatever wage
they give to one person they
have to give to everyone.
In this video, we're going to review
what we know about a monopsony employer,
and then we're going to add a twist
that deals with minimum
wages, which are going to be,
it's going to be a little
bit counterintuitive.
So just as a review, a
monopsony in general is
when you have one buyer and many sellers.
And a monopsony employer is the situation
where that one buyer,
they're the buyer of labor,
of that factor of production.
And so you have one employer.
And then the many sellers,
these are the sellers of labor,
the people who are
providing their own labor.
So these are all of the workers.
And we've already studied
this in previous videos,
but I will review it right now.
We can draw our classic axes
where you have your wage rate here
in dollars on the vertical axis.
You have your quantity of labor
right there in the horizontal axis.
We can think about our
marginal revenue product
of labor curve.
So every incremental unit of labor,
the firm gets a little
bit less benefit in,
measured by revenue, so less
and less and less revenue.
And so this is marginal revenue product.
This is marginal revenue product of labor
'cause we're talking about labor markets.
If this was another factor of production,
it would be marginal
revenue product of capital
or of land or whatever else.
And then we could think about
the marginal factor cost.
If this were not a monopsony employer,
well, then the marginal
factor cost would just be
the market wage rate, so it
would look something like that.
And we've already seen this,
if this was an employer
in a perfectly competitive labor market.
But this is not an employer
They're the only employer
in this small town.
They're the big industry,
and so they're going
to have their own unique
labor supply curve.
So it might look something like this,
labor,
I'll just write supply of labor,
supply of labor.
And you might be tempted,
and we thought about this in
previous video, to say, hey,
this is going to be the marginal
factor cost curve of labor.
'Cause you say, well, you know,
that first person is willing
to work for that much,
the second person is willing
or the second unit of labor.
But remember, we said or
we're making the assumption
that even a monopsony
employer, if it pays,
if it has to raise the wage
to get that second unit of labor,
it has to raise the wage for everyone.
So when it goes further and
further up the supply curve,
as it hires more and more and more,
it's not just paying
the incremental amount
to that incremental person,
it has to pay it to everyone.
So its marginal factor cost is
going to go up twice as fast.
So the marginal factor cost curve
is going to look something like this.
So it's going to look like this,
our marginal factor cost curve.
And this is, of course,
when we're dealing with
a monopsony employer.
And so what is the
rational quantity of labor
for this firm to hire?
Well, it's going to keep hiring as long as
on the margin, every incremental
unit of labor it brings on,
it gets more revenue than
it has to incur in cost.
So as long as the marginal
revenue product is higher
than the marginal factor
cost, it keeps hiring
all the way until this
point when they're equal.
So it would hire,
it would hire this quantity of labor.
And what is the wage it would have to pay?
Sometimes we just instinctively
go back to this dot.
We just want to go horizontally
'cause we're thinking about
thinking about equilibrium
prices and quantities.
But remember, this, at this quantity,
this is not the wage up here,
the wage is defined by the supply curve.
And so this is the wage
that the firm would pay.
Now I'm going to add a twist.
What do you think would happen
if this town said, all right,
well, this employer has
too much power here,
and we think they should pay higher wages.
What do you think would happen
if the town increased the,
or enacted a minimum wage
that is higher than W sub one?
And actually, let's assume a situation
where the town enacts a minimum wage
that's right here at W sub two.
What does the marginal factor cost curve
now look like for this monopsony employer?
And now what would be
the rational quantity
of labor to employ?
Pause this video, and think about it.
Well, in a world where the
government sets a minimum wage,
well, then it starts to
feel, at least graphically,
a lot more like a
competitive labor market.
Although, this isn't due to market forces,
this is due to just some
type of government law.
But then the monopsony
employer will no longer
have its own supply of
labor curve like this,
and it would no longer
have this upward-sloping
marginal factor cost curve.
I'll call this marginal
factor cost curve one.
Now the government has defined the wage.
So no matter how many people they hire,
they're going to pay that same wage.
So the marginal factor
cost is now going to be
a horizontal line at that
wage that the government set,
so the marginal factor cost sub two,
and this is due to a
minimum wage.
Now, what is the rational
quantity to hire?
Well, like always, it's rational
to keep hiring as long as you're on,
at every incremental unit of labor,
your marginal revenue product is higher
than your marginal factor cost.
So they keep hiring all
the way until this point,
and so this is the rational
quantity for them to hire.
Let's call that Q sub two.
And we already know the wage,
that's the minimum wage
that the government has set.
Now, something very
counterintuitive has happened.
Now, all of a sudden, it's rational
for the firm to hire more people.
And the reason why I say
it's counterintuitive,
if I'm just running
some type of a business
and all of a sudden I
have to pay higher wages,
well, I might say, well,
gee, I can't afford
to pay as many people, so I'm not going,
I actually might have
to reduce my employment.
And that might be the case
if we're dealing with other
types of labor markets,
if I'm not a monopsony employer.
But at least theoretically,
based on all the assumptions we've made,
and we can debate on
how transferable this is
to the real world,
if you have a monopsony
employer, what this did is,
is this actually caused
the employer to hire more.
And you might say why is that?
Well, now the employer
is paying the same wage
regardless of how many people they hire.
Before, every incremental
person they hired,
every incremental unit of labor,
it raised the wage for everyone.
And so in some ways or in a very real way,
this made it rational for
the firm to hire more.
Now, that doesn't mean that the firm
is better off in this situation.
It's just splitting the,
it's just splitting that
marginal revenue product
differently between the
firm and the employers.
In the old situation,
the firm was able to capture
everything above the wage line
and below the marginal
revenue product line.
So the firm was able
to capture all of that.
While, in this new world,
the firm is capturing
everything above the wage line
and below the marginal
revenue product line.
So it is a different area.
But the other thing to keep in mind is
I picked a very particular wage
that would cause this horizontal
marginal factor cost curve
to intersect the marginal
revenue product curve
right where the marginal
intersects the supply of labor curve.
I could've picked another wage.
So the government could have
overshot, and it could've said,
hey, we're gonna raise the minimum wage
up here to W sub three.
And then what would happen?
Well, then your marginal factor
cost curve would be up here,
marginal factor cost sub three,
and the rational quantity to
hire would actually go down,
which is a little bit more intuitive
for what would happen when
you enact a minimum wage.
But at least theoretically,
when you're dealing with
a monopsony employer,
there could be a situation
where forcing the wages up
could cause the employer to hire more,
which is counterintuitive.